シコシコ
どうも
ピー♪
ＴＶと
いやいやｗｗｗ
ついに
はい
一年間
ラーメンを我慢して
はい
すごいですねホントに
せっかくだったら
一発目はめちゃくちゃ旨いラーメン食いたいと思って
はい
今日ちょっとすする君のところにお邪魔しております
いや、もうホント声かけてくれて光栄ですほんとに
とゆうことですするＴＶの
はい
おススメのラーメンですか？
そうです。
めちゃくちゃおススメのラーメンを
今日は
紹介していきます
一年ぶりのラーメンなんで
はい
ラーメン食っていこうと思います
レッツゴー(棒読み)
ブッｗｗｗｗ
♫～
あ、ここにいろいろサインが
サインいろいろありますよ
いや、死ぬうま死ぬうまｗ
普通にラーメン
食べて
ラーメンと、まぁ
生卵、僕はおススメしてます
なるほどなるほど
はい
他におススメは？
んまぁ
豚の酢とかだったら豚・・・
おなしゃっす！
はい
よろしくお願いします
何食ったんすか？ラーメン食べずに
いや、もう牛丼すねぇ～
あぁ、牛丼と・・・
なんか、牛丼に逃げちゃって
二年前に食べ過ぎちゃって、ラーメンを
はいはいはい
当時、毎日スープまで飲んでるから
あ、もう全部飲んでて
チャーシュー丼とかも食って
ヤバ
んなことしてたら
なんか、人間ドックで
中性脂肪がホントに
体の中に結構、害が
あ、そうです、そうですね
はいはい
で、ヤバいって言われて
ラーメン禁止に至ったっていう
あ、それでなんだ！
・・・・・・・・・(無言)
なってねぇな！
はい、ラーメンです
ありざまーす
(突然の変顔ｗｗｗ)
いや、こんぐらいでしょ
こんなもんすか？
あーありざます
はい
いただきまーす
すぅげぇ～
♫～～～
もう、食いたいっすね
うん、食いたいっす
もう、食いましょう
じゃあ、
一年ぶりのラーメン
いただきまぁーす!!!
いただきまーす
やばい、マジでホントに１年ぶりですよ
ヤバいっすね、一年ぶりは結構、想像できないもん
え、だって毎日食べてるんすよね？
いやいや、いいでしょそこは
♫～～～
ホントに食べるのかぁ～
あははｗｗｗ
いいのかなぁ
いや、いいすよ
♫～
うわぁ～
食うのかぁ
いや、やめることもできますよ
いや、ダメダメダメダメ
いやもう、俺は、これを食べるために
はい
一年間頑張ってきたこともあるんで
では、
いただきます！
行ってください
いただきますっ
いただきまーす
♫～～～
♫～～～～～
ふはははｗｗｗ
ホントにうめぇ！
これが一年間ラーメン食べなかった人のリアクションだな！
マジでおいしい！
あははｗｗｗ
よかったっすホントに
♫～
おぉ～
なに
食べさせたらいいかすげぇ考えたんですけど
やっぱこうゆう
がっつけるラーメンがいいかなっと思って
泣いてる!?
泣いてるの!?
すする君に紹介してもらったラーメンは
今まで食べてきたすべての食べ物の中で
一番おいしい
心から
そう感じたんだ
快楽
食べましたぁ
はい
ご馳走様でした
ようやく食えた
至極の一品でございました
すごい、いや、よかったですホントに
ホントにおいしかったですありがとうございました
別に僕が作った訳じゃないですけど
全然僕じゃないんですけどｗｗｗ
店長ありがとうございます!!!
ご馳走様でしたぁ～
いや、でもやっぱりね
我慢して初めて見える
光景もあるんですね
いや、ありますね
なんか、また今年も我慢しようと思ってるんですけど
ちょっと、また近いうちに発表したいと思います！
はい
最高の一品でございました！
ありがとうございました
ご馳走様でした
というわけで、
え～今年はすする君がラーメン一年禁止しますｗｗ
いや、しないしないｗｗｗ
ED♫～
今回、字幕をつけさせてもらいました
黒龍です。夜一時までかかりました(汗)
コメント欄のほうに感想をお願いします！
待ってます！